It's impossible to imagine
the long-awaited sequel to Blade Runner
without some version of the iconic music
that Vangelis composed for the original.
That's because the Blade Runner score
is more than a score.
It's an indispensable element of the movie.
I mean, you could make that argument
about almost all film music,
a movie minus its music
is not the same movie.
That's true too, if you were to swap
one kind of music for another.
[cheerful music playing]
In the video I did on
Howard Shore's incredible leitmotifs
in the Lord of the Rings,
I tried to show how the score
helped guide and elevate
the emotional beats of the story.
It's great work from a great composer,
and hugely influential on the trilogy.
I think Blade Runner's music is different,
it plays a different role.
The score isn't laid
on top of the visuals.
It's not a guide, or an addition.
The music is sort of baked into the DNA
of the movie itself.
All the audio that you hear,
including score, sound design,
and dialogue
it's tightly integrated,
each blurs into the others.
This integration is really what separates Blade Runner from other science fiction films.
After all, electronic music had been a staple
of science fiction cinema
for three decades by then,
going all the way back to Bernard Herrmann's
use of the theremin
in "The Day the Earth Stood Still."
Herrmann and other revolutionary composers,
like Louis and Bebe Barron,
used winding, bending, sputtering electronic sounds
to evoke aliens and alien planets.
Blade Runner is somewhere in the middle
between the amelodic soundscapes
of Forbidden Planet
and the grand, symphonic themes
of something like Star Wars.
Vangelis is pulling from that same toolbox
of electronic sounds,
but these noises are put to use
for a more musical purpose.
In order to achieve that dream-like quality
that the film has,
the audience shouldn't be able to identify
where the music ends and the world begins.
The atmospherics that infuse this scene are
a good example of what I'm talking about.
They sound a little bit like wind chimes,
something that could very well be in the space,
and match pretty well with the dancing light
on the walls.
And yet, the sound is so layered
with faint computer-y noises
that it could also be a machine
somewhere in the room.
It also serves as a kind of atmospheric bed from which
the clearly non-diegetic,
not in-the-world strings rise
as Rachel enters.
RACHEL: "Do you like our owl?"
Even the dialogue has a lot of reverb,
giving it the same dreamy quality
as the score and the sound effects.
RACHEL: I'm Rachel.
DECKARD: Deckard.
Of course, reverberation is
absolutely everywhere
in Blade Runner.
You could even say that it's the manipulation of reverb that gives Blade Runner its distinct feeling.
And though Vangelis is such a virtuoso at wielding it,
the digital reverb that you hear in this movie was something relatively new to music at the time.
The world's first digital reverberation machine,
the EMT-250,
was released only six years before Blade Runner premiered in 1982.
We all have a natural sense of reverb.
We hear it when we're in big spaces,
how our voice reverberates
and decays across the room.
Digital reverb uses algorithms
to extend that decay even more.
The Lexicon-224, which is what Vangelis used
for Blade Runner, could extend decays
up to 70 seconds, allowing you to make spacey,
ethereal sounds like this:
[SPACEY, ETHEREAL SOUND]
The emphasis on reverb accomplishes a few things:
as essayist Andrew Stiller noted,
"heavy reverb, because it implies a huge,
enclosed, hard-surface space,
creates a mood of mystery and paranoia."
It also gives everything a feeling of distance,
as if the audio is coming from far away, like in a dream.
Finally, reverberation blends things together.
This is one of the crucial ways Vangelis
folds separate audio sources into one aural master track, because that is the goal here.
Every scene is composed to create this cohesive acoustic environment.
Sometimes, the emphasis is on dialogue
or sound effects,
other times it's on the nostalgic music that calls back
to classic film noir.
[PAUSE]
Except that solo saxophone was never actually used
in classic film noir,
which is a whole 'nother video; but anyway-
[RESUME]
Most of these scenes were interpreted
by Vangelis on the spot.
The way he composed the music for Blade Runner
was by watching
the freshly edited scenes
on a screen in his studio
and playing whatever they evoked
in him at the time.
He used primarily the Yamaha CS-80,
an analog synthesizer featured so prominently
in Blade Runner
that Vangelis has his own section
in the CS-80 Wikipedia page.
Even today, the CS-80
is prized among audiophiles.
It seems like anybody who ever writes about it
describes it as
a living, breathing thing.
That's partly down to the fact
that the keys were pressure sensitive,
so the sound that it produced
has a marvelous acoustic quality.
In a way, it's the perfect instrument
for Blade Runner.
A machine, with the ability to match
the emotional weight of the real thing.
VANGELIS:  See, in one go,
you can have from there...
[drum crash]
to there.
[arpeggio]
It's different sound,
to there, which is...
[synth]
different sound,
to there, which is different again
[choral synth]
As much as possible,
Vangelis used his spontaneous,
first-tape compositions.
And the result is a deeply personal
reaction to the images,
a second vision that fuses
with the director's own.
Vangelis, like the great composer
Edgard Varèse before him,
attempted to bring to life
the complete sound profile of the city
interpreted through the genres
of Blade Runner.
Anybody who's lived in a large metropolis
knows that sound is a constant feature there.
At night, you might hear a siren,
or a scream somewhere in the distance.
We may not have wheezing or sputtering machines,
but these days, we sure have a lot of beeping ones.
Vangelis strings all these
disparate noises together
with musical themes
that are stunning and appropriate.
When the music swirls,
it's as if it's coming
from within the characters themselves,
like an internal cry or a release.
Unfortunately, Vangelis isn't coming back
for Blade Runner 2049.
His job is going to Johann Johannsson,
a great composer who's worked
with director Denis Villeneuve three times before.
[EDIT: As of the release of the movie, the composers have changed to Hans Zimmer and Benjamin Wallfisch]
I don't envy him, I mean,
everybody is going to be waiting
for him to play
someone else's iconic music.
If I were him, I'd resist the urge
to mimic Vangelis completely.
As much as I'd like to hear
every classic note again.
The sequel deserves music as personal
and human as its original.
I'm excited to hear Johann Johannsson's
interpretation of a world
that so many of us are so eager to return to.
Hey everybody, thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by The Great Courses Plus.
The Great Courses Plus is an on-demand video learning service,
which basically means that it's got around
7,000 online video lecture series from some great Ivy League professors and other professors about all kinds of subjects:
math, history, archaeology, et cetera.
One that I think you should really check out is called "Music in the Brain" by Professor Patel,
which explores in depth the neurological relationship to music over 18 awesome episodes.
[If] you go to thegreatcoursesplus.com/nerdwriter (it's the first link in the description),
you can get a 30-day free trial, and after that annual memberships are $14.99 a month and monthly memberships are $19.99 a month.
Thanks guys. I'll see you all next time.